-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden had his annual
physical today at Walter Reid.
Doctors say he is fit
as a fiddle,
specifically this 300-year-old
Stradivarius.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. President Biden
today had his annual physical,
and I think Fox News messed with
his eye chart.
[ Laughter ]
It wouldn't count.
Wouldn't be legally binding.
According to a new report, top
Democrats privately think that
President Biden is too old for
re-election but worry that his
decision not to run would cause
chaos in the Democratic Party.
You guys didn't see this coming?
We elected a half finished game
of Jenga and now
you're all saying, "Oh,
everybody move your drinks!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke publicly
today about the aerial objects
shot down by the military.
Said Biden, "The American people
deserve to know
how much fun this week has been
for me."
[ Laughter ]
Acting FAA administrator
Billy Nolen testified before
the Senate yesterday on
the agency's handling of recent
near collisions at airports
and assured Americans that
flying is safe.
I don't know. At this point,
the best can you say is that
it's safer than traveling via
balloon.
[ Laughter ]
I would not want to travel via
balloon right now.
The FAA this week announced
plans for an airline industry
safety summit after a recent
series of near accidents.
But don't worry, you only need
to attend
if you're in the exit row.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Oye, boy, oh, boy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A lawyer for Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz said yesterday that
the Justice Department informed
Gaetz that they will not move
forward with charges relating to
his sex trafficking
investigation and that Gaetz has
learned his lesson.
Venmo set to private.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times" published
an op-ed yesterday about
Republican presidential hopeful
Nikki Haley
titled "Nikki Haley will not be
the next president."
Yeah, I'm not falling for
that one anymore.
The last guy they said would
never be the next president,
turns out he was
the next president.
Also, still might be
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk said yesterday that
artificial intelligence has
great promise and capability but
added that it
comes with "great danger."
So either he's one of the great
minds of our generation
or he finally saw
"The Terminator."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
Cleveland and Detroit are
the least expensive U.S. cities
for single people
in the same way that
the cheapest car
you can buy is just to walk.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was National
Do a Grouch a Favor Day.
Okay. Off the top of my head,
let him crash with you?
Hey, it's our friend who lives
in the garbage and eats trash.
Welp, see you later.
That was a monologue, everybody.
We are off and running.